as you can see I'm a big fan of Mean
Girls and recently rachel mcadams
confirmed that she would be interested
in a sequel to the iconic film which of
course makes me so happy so the actors
reviewed the exciting news during the
heroes on health
Kovach 19 stream Athan when she was
asked which role she would like to
revisit I mean it would be fun to play
Regina George later in her life and see
where life took her is that ever been a
discussion or Mean Girls I think only in
joking but not not quite seriously not
quite seriously yet I still have hope
now those remarks are similar to the
ones for Mean Girls co-star Lindsay
Lohan made on a recent as I said of
David Spade's lights out take a look
well I think that I was hanging on to
that for a really long idea I kind of
wanted to come back with like a Mean
Girls to when she passed and work with
Tina and the whole crew again and Mark
Waters and that was really what I wanted
I was really excited to do that so and I
and that's all in their hands really so
that would definitely be an exciting
thing now in that same live stream
Rachel also spoke about the longevity of
a film like Mean Girls and its impact on
pop culture
let's hope Mean Girls has health girls
to be nicer to each other not the other
way around yeah I mean it's really
bizarre you know I feel so lucky to be a
part of something that's stuck around a
little
even a little bit you know that was
never anything I imagined happening in
life so so yeah it's it's it's a strange
and surreal still she also told the New
York Times a few years back about the
fact that her Mean Girls character still
haunts her today saying quote does
Regina George haunt me every day she
does have that quality I have to thank
Regina George for giving me some
longevity I'm forever grateful to Tina
Fey and Mark Waters she's also since
theorized about what Regina would be
like as an adult
saying quote Regina's probably had a few
babies who are plotting your demise in
the
sounds about right someone like the
potential future of Regina
it seems like Rachel is enjoying being a
mom admitting that her two-year-old son
is keeping her entertained while in
quarantine I have a very welcome
distraction in my son who is too and so
that's pretty much what I do all the
time Wow great rachel mcadams this one
mom of the year because she's sent her
two-year-old was a welcome distraction
that goes against everything I've seen
on insta this week it's true he's so
entertaining I thought about that like
when I rather be alone in quarantine or
with my family and you know their day is
sure but I mean I would be so bored
without him around to make it so fun so
you know we've been like I said we live
sort of out in the country so there's a
little farm down the road we can go and
look at the animals and we perfect doing
some planting some okra and I mean I do
the planting and he acts so be honest
would you be interested in the sequel to
Mean Girls just to see what Regina would
be like as a mom let me know in the
comments below